20 new volunteers were virtually sworn
in today to advocate for the best
interests of children in the foster care
the court appointed special advocates
also known as casa
will be assigned to 52 children in the
foster care system
many are abused or neglected children
here in clark county
now it started in 1980 casa program
currently has 386 volunteers
but they are looking to increase their
team to 1 000.
it's a two-year commitment and
willingness to spend time with the
children
are some of the requirements you are the
voice for these children
it's very important if you imagine being
placed in foster care
being in child welfare system the trauma
the children have suffered
as being a victim of abuse and neglect
the trauma being separated from their
caretakers perhaps
maybe from their siblings hopefully not
but maybe separate from their siblings
maybe changing schools but think of the
trauma these kids go through
well among the new volunteers is a
teacher a business owner a unlv
student and a fire department employee
also a former foster youth former
military
and former law enforcement officer all
part
of this new group congratulations to all
of them